good afternoon today we're going to talk
about evolution or is it evolution
evolution this is a tough one because
they're more questions than answers on
this one today the questions we're going
to answer or try to address let's say
where did viruses come from no idea just
speculations where are they going no
idea just speculations but we have ideas
but it's hard to predict how are they
getting there that we I can tell you a
bit about and I can also tell you about
how would we know so for me that's a
little unsettling to not know half of
the answers that we're going to talk
about but that's evolution though the
techniques of modern biology lets us get
at least halfway to the answer of some
of these questions we know that as host
populations multiply there are viruses
that are selected for that can infect
them and this has happened since the
beginning of life we now know that new
populations emerge every day this really
wasn't something that was appreciated in
the 50s or even in the 60s we also know
that viral populations can shape the way
hosts evolve they can change them
extensively so they are a big force in
evolution and of course if you can't
adapt to a virus that it's particularly
lethal virus infection then you're going
to be made extinct and this is really a
theoretical issue because I don't
believe we have any proof for any such
extinction caused by viruses but I'm
sure it has happened over time now the
public interestingly is confronted with
the consequences of
illusion on a daily basis even though a
good part of the public doesn't believe
in evolution it's happening right in
front of them so new diseases are
emerging like AIDS which emerged in the
80s West Nile coming to the US hepatitis
C brand new infection Ebola Marburg this
is evolution so I don't understand how
you cannot believe in it when it's right
in front of you flu every year common
colds new common cold virus is not just
the same old ones but new ones are
emerged and discovered on a regular
basis drug resistance as we talked about
last time this is all evolution so
evolution is happening right in front of
us and I think part of the problem is
that viruses evolve faster than many
people can understand if as an
evolutionary biologist once said to me a
virus is not a cow the point is that
cows take a long time to reproduce and
when they do they make another cow but a
virus reproduces very quickly and it
makes billions of viruses so even when
you think about how these two organisms
evolved they are very different and the
other thing is that you know viruses you
can't even see so how can people believe
that they are evolving or that they can
have these effects on host populations
so the diversity is incredible it's
actually something I didn't appreciate
until not too long ago just how diverse
the viral is and as a consequence we are
just beginning to understand the forces
the selection forces that drive
evolution we'll talk a little bit about
that today why infections emerge and
next time we will talk about specific
conditions that lead to provide new
viruses emerging today we're going to
talk about the nuts and bolts the other
the third point there is very
interesting the participation of viruses
in the ecosystem viruses have huge roles
to play in the carbon cycles and other
cycles nitrogen sulfur cycles as well
and the turnover of
various life-forms very interesting
we're just beginning to understand this
and what does all this mean for our own
survival just think if you took away all
the viruses she can somehow do that if
you could take away all the viruses just
like that what would happen I think that
we would all perish most likely but we
don't know someone will model this on a
computer someday so what is viral
evolution it's simply the constant
change of a viral population in the face
of selection pressures and if this viral
population cannot adapt do we know now
it will disappear so the viruses are
engineered to be able to change and
adapt we know that they do change we've
talked about it a lot in this course
we'll get a little bit at the nuts and
bolts today diversity is amazing if you
learn one thing in this course it is
that they display incredible diversity
and that's the main reason why viruses
are so successful so we don't have great
diversity we do other things to be
successful but viruses the key is to
make a lot of viruses and eventually one
or two of those will succeed so today
we're going to talk about the sources of
this diversity which is mutation and
recombination and these are things you
already know about so much of this
should be a review for you so when we
talk about populations I also want you
to know that we're talking always about
when we talk about it evolution we're
always talking about populations not
individual virus particles this will
become more clear in a moment as when we
define a few terms so not the individual
particles populations are a raise of
mutants okay think of the virus
population as a collection of mutants
and that is what evolves not the
individual particles and again these
mutants are made in huge quantities
don't think of an individual virion as
an average okay we used to think this
way we used to get a sequence and we
said this is influenza virus but it's no
longer the case
so we have to always think about the
population as we say we are really
population biologists even though we
don't want to be them because that's
what you're measuring when you're
studying virus infections the whole
population and so this famous biologist
Stephen Jay Gould said when it comes to
viral evolution the median is not the
message I don't know if any of you know
who Marshall McLuhan is do they still
teach him anybody know who Marshall
McLuhan is vision had no it's amazing
Marshall McLuhan was a guy who analyzed
media back in the 60s his famous saying
was the medium is the message so he said
if you watch television it's not so much
the content on TV but it's actually the
TV itself that gives you the experience
and so even Jay cool google made a
clever take off on that the median is
not the message the median of a viral
population is not what's important it's
not the average it's the entire
population because it's the population
that provides the avenues for survival
it could be any of the many virus
particles in a yield could be the
survivor and even the most rare genotype
maybe the most common after a single
selection event and often you don't see
this and even if we try and measure it
we don't see it in the laboratory but
this is happening all the time so when
you think about viruses don't think
about the average think about the entire
population and what's possible from that
now virus evolution has four main
drivers and you could almost see this as
a multiple choice question with a fifth
one right all of the above large numbers
of progeny very important for
revolutions large numbers of mutants
Kwazii species effects will talk about
that and selection so these are the four
drivers of virus evolution and you can
see that they're very different from say
how we evolved we undergo selection it
takes a
to select variants of human populations
we're not quazy species as far as we
know we don't make large numbers of
mutants we don't make large numbers of
progeny so this is why viruses are not
cows they are a unique entity in terms
of evolution and and the making of large
numbers of progeny shouldn't come as a
surprise to you we've talked about this
in terms of hepatitis sorry human
immunodeficiency virus these are just
some numbers for HIV and hepatitis B
virus to underscore that viruses make a
lot of particles when they infect cells
here is a half-life of Hep B and HIV in
the plasma so HIV an amazingly short
half-life in part a result of immune
responses but also a simple turnover
have be 24 hours daily tone over half of
all the virions made of Hep B it turned
over in a day ninety percent for HIV
total production in the blood over 10 to
the 11th for hep b and over 10 to the
ninth for HIV so that's what we mean by
huge numbers of progeny and then similar
numbers in virus-infected cells but
quantitatively different and this is
what we mean by having grounds for
selection you make a lot of particles
and you have some kind of selection
whether it be the immune response which
is responsible for a lot of the turnover
or simply going into a new cell or going
into a different host so replicating
viruses make a lot of mutant genomes and
evolution will happen only when
mutations occur remember that if you
don't Mutai you can't change and how do
you make mutations of course you know
the answer and that happens during
nucleic acid synthesis which is an
inherently error-prone process and
probably has evolved to be that way if
it many experiments have been done which
show that if you reduce the error
frequency of polymerase is that those
whatever organism it is your studying
don't fare well under selective
conditions and we know that for RNA
viruses these are the masters of
error-prone replication that polymerase
not correct the errors that they may
call polymerase is of course make errors
but the RNA polymerase is don't have
error correction that's really important
to remember and as we know the average
error frequency for an RNA virus is
anywhere from one in 10,000 or a hundred
thousand mistakes so one mistake in
every 10,000 or hundred thousand
nucleotides polymerised right depends on
the virus there are variations so again
what that means is in a 10,000
nucleotide RNA virus genome you have one
mutation / replication cycle if the
mutation frequency is one in 10,000 so
every time that genome is copied there
will be one mistake if that is the error
frequency so that's a lot because in a
single cell the genome is copied tens of
thousands of time and that's just in one
cell and this has led to what we call
the quazy species concept and this arose
in studies of a virus of bacteria a
bacteriophage called q beta and it was a
study which I remember I was a graduate
student at the time I had no idea what
this meant here's the paper it was
published in cell in 1978 and the lead
author was Esteban Domingo this is the
fellow who told me once that viruses are
not cows he said also they are not fruit
flies they're totally different from
everything AQ beta phage population is
in a dynamic equilibrium with viral
mutation rate and being strongly
selected against on the other the genome
of q beta cannot be described as a
defined unique structure but rather as a
weighted average a large number of
different individual sequences so this
was really never appreciated for any
organism so it came as a surprise the
reason why it was discovered is because
techniques were developed that could be
used to say there's a lot of variation
in this genome sequencing the genome is
not enough to give you a sense of the
variation so this was ahead of it
I'm not appreciated by most of our
ologist so I was in good company a lot
of people didn't understand it took many
years for me to get and I think even
today a lot of biologists don't
understand what it means to have a quazy
species so again the virus populations
are dynamic distributions which means
they're always changing of non-identical
but related replicons in other words the
influenza virus replicating in a Cell
the sequence is always an influenza
virus sequence but there's a huge
variation in what is going on the number
of progeny produced I shouldn't say the
number the number of different sequences
among the progeny is huge they're all
would be recognizable as influenza virus
if you sequence them all but they're
incredibly variants and that's what we
mean by a quazy species a species had
come to to evolve to mean that in an
organism that can reproduce with other
members of the same organism and the
idea was that the sequence was fixed
with within a certain range and so this
went way beyond that and hence it was
called a quazy species yeah okay now
this is a picture of a quazy species as
best we can do it we actually haven't
been yet able to sequence the entire
virus population and say this is the
quazy species because the error rate of
sequencing technology is still too high
to be able to do this we'll get there in
the next few years I think this is the
best we can do this is a part of an RNA
virus population obviously it's not the
entire population because there are less
than a hundred members here but you can
see each of them is the genome and it
shows you that every genome is unique in
this population has different changes
with respect to another and that's what
the different symbols mean if you take
an average of this population you get
the virus sequence on the bottom and
what's important is that that looks like
very few members of the entire
population so the average isn't really
making up the entire population if you
sequence this genome this is the
sequence at the bottom that you will get
because sequencing techniques
aren't sensitive enough to pick up
beyond a certain amount of change now
when i was doing sequencing in the 70s
and aiding you could not detect anything
that was less than fifteen percent of a
population so you always got an average
which was this year we can now do better
but as i said we can't get down to
individual molecules yet although we
will get there now because of this fact
that there is a quazy species and RNA
viruses maybe DNA viruses as well but
hasn't been as well studied when you
infect a cell or when you get infected
you're not infected by a single virion
or a single sequence you're infected by
a population really diverse population
so right away you can imagine strange
things are going to happen you're going
to have all kinds of selections of what
comes out may be totally different from
what goes in you remember the virus that
infects you wasn't made in you you apply
different selections than the person who
gave you that virus so there's going to
be enormous changes so that all the
progeny very odds that are made in any
particular cell or host or products of
selective forces inside the host so
again when you get infected with someone
else's virus the virus you get is a
product of what happened in that host
and every host is different and someday
we will be able to do these experiments
where we do an infection of a host and
do the total sequence of what is in that
host total sequence of what's released
in the total sequence of what's made in
the next host and so on we can't do that
yet the survivors that reinfect the new
hosts are also the product of selective
forces outside the host so the drying
that can happen the UV radiation low pH
whatever the environment is when those
variants are released from the first
person those apply their selection as
well to the to the Kwazii species to the
entire population now in the laboratory
we generally work with pretty restricted
quazy species they're they're restricted
because the nature of experiments are
such that the cells are relatively
homogeneous and so forth and so in
laboratories you can have extreme
fluctuations in genotype and phenotype
because you can have selections on small
populations and as you will
see that results in massive changes this
doesn't happen in hosts we think because
there are more diverse conditions when
you go from host to host for example you
have a lot more variability in the kinds
of viruses that are produced so here is
a genome sequence has anybody know what
virus it is there's no way you would
know I I know because it's folio because
the first four bases are TT TT g but
this is a myth now I'm not going to ask
you that don't worry it's just when you
work with something for 30 years you get
to know the sequence up at the way I
really know the sequence I don't because
this is a quazy species and this is just
the average when you make the RNA and
you sequence it by whatever technique
you get an average unless you go very
deep and that's what we call deep
sequencing these days when you get close
to individual molecules but not quite
then you can pick up variations but the
the sequences you see in GenBank which
are typical of this you go on to GenBank
and you search for a viral sequence you
will get a printout and it's a little
misleading it's all authoritative it
this is this is the sequence of this
influenza virus isolated from this
person in this city on this date but
it's not the virus looked nothing like
this that's what I want you to remember
that the sequence is just some kind of a
representation that we use as a starting
point so the sequence again clusters
around an average which is what you get
when you use your techniques but every
genome can be different from every other
so it's really interesting when you
think of it you have a sequence like
this and let's say you clone it when you
clone an RNA genome as a DNA you
restrict the sequence you no longer have
a quazy species you really do that DNA
molecule have one sequence maybe you
have a little variation because even as
a plasmid replicates in bacteria there
are some errors but nothing like the
Kwazii species so when you make
mutations in genomes starting at a DNA
level it's totally different from what
is going on in the cell so the effects
you see may be totally totally
irrelevant compared with what would
happen in
normal infection so this is something
that's very difficult to deal with
because many people make a living making
mutations and drawing conclusions from
them but in fact many of them may not be
correct because they don't represent
what happens in a population in an
infected cell so this sequence as I said
it's very unlikely that a genome with
this sequence is actually replicating in
the picture we showed before there was
one consensus sequence but may not it
may not be there more likely that there
are other sequences as well so what does
all of this mean in terms of evolution
first of all it means survival of the
fittest a very rare genome in that
mixture in that quazy species may happen
to survive a selection event just
randomly and then you will find that
mutation in progeny genome so it may be
one genome in the original kazi species
but if it's selected for positively will
be found you also say survival of the
survivors because even though that
original mutation was selected for all
the others weren't selected for they
just come along with it they are linked
to it in the genome but they're not
selected because they there their
presence is not necessary so selection
gives you a new diverse population the
only thing common with the previous
population is that this one mutation or
a few mutations were present in the
previous population now those have been
selected for and they predominate but
again you have a quazy species again you
have a a highly heterogeneous population
of viruses now DNA viruses remember
don't have anywhere near as much
variation as RNA viruses consequently
they have a narrower host range I'm glad
dr. Silverstein isn't here today would
probably argue but he would be just
being defensive for his chosen viruses
because in fact they do have a narrower
host range most viral infections in the
world are carried out by RNA viruses
they have they often cause persistent
infections and maybe that's an
adaptation to
having a lower mutation rate because
they come become part of the host it may
not even replicate for long periods of
time they have less replication than RNA
viruses in general fewer genome copies
are made and of course the genome
replication is not as error-prone they
have proof reading so they can correct
their mistakes but they don't proofread
every mistake they do let some slip
through there is an error rate it's
higher it's much lower than with RNA
viruses but it's still there is still
error otherwise you would not be able to
survive a virus has to make mistakes any
organism has to make errors in order to
survive selection so as a consequence of
this higher fidelity if you will most
DNA viruses generate less diversity and
involves slower but they do evolve and
we have lots of evidence for that in
terms of sequences okay selection is the
key here also one of the drivers of
evolution this is what gives you
diversity and single mutations that are
selected for so it's it's a little
counterintuitive in other words you
select for mutations that give you some
kind of advantage yet if you don't have
a population to begin with you will
eventually die out so you have to have a
very diverse population from which to
select specific mutations that have an
advantageous effect in a certain
circumstance we there are some nice
examples of selection and side of hosts
that we've talked about and one of them
is during the end stages of AIDS old of
your eons that are present at that point
are t-cell tropic in other words they
use the cxcr4 coreceptor remember HIV
can utilize one of two coreceptors so at
the end stage of age the viruses that
predominate that have been selected for
during the infection which can be many
years as you remember engage this
receptor but when you pass the infection
to a new host that host in that house
the initial replicating genomes RM
tropic viruses macrophage topic that
engage the other coreceptor
cr5 a really nice example of selection
for survival and a host for some reason
these viruses RB are good at being
transmitted and these are good at
replicating extensively within the host
so what we say is that these genomes
have passed through a bottleneck and
only a few of the many many genomes that
are present have passed on to the new
host so the virions that eventually
cause the immunosuppression are in fact
not the ones that are the best to travel
from host to host which is shown by
these first two bullet points here
alright so that's what that's an example
of what I mean by selection from a very
large population yeah the earlier I said
that you can make various organisms with
a lower error rate and they don't do
well so if AG increased mutation rates
are selected for during evolution so not
only do we select for mutants but we
select for the ability to make them it's
very important so you can engineer
mutations and viral polymerase is for
example and these changes can reduce the
incorporation of errors these we call
anti mutators also been done in
organisms like e.coli and what's learned
from these studies of these mutants they
don't have a selective advantage when
you mix together say a wild-type virus
and a virus with an anti mutator
together and you ask in a cell culture
which one wins an animal which one wins
these viruses with reduced with
increased fidelity just don't do well so
lower rates are neither invent Aegis nor
selected for those mutated viruses are
never selected for in any experiments
and often these viruses are less
pathogenic there's an excellent example
in polio a single amino acid change in
the viral RNA polymerase which makes it
make less fewer errors that mutation
makes the virus less pathogenic and you
can't it cannot compete with wild-type
virus so increased mutations rates have
been so
elected for an hour positive force in
virus evolution so many people think of
mutation is a bad thing but what I want
you to understand is that for viruses
which we're talking about today they are
essential you have to make mutations
otherwise you can't survive and of
course in all other organism it's the
same just that the rate is much lower
now the amount of mutation that a
organism or a virus can sustain or
withstand is called the error threshold
the capacity to make a lot of mutants is
an advantage as we have just told but
there is a point where you have
selection and survival balanced alright
so the fidelity in the mutation rate
have to be in balance with one another
and in fact that mutation in polio
polymerase that I just talked about was
selected as a consequence of this error
threshold I'll tell you about that in a
moment so the limit is called the error
threshold it's the point beyond which
you cannot go in terms of the frequency
of mutations if you go beyond it you are
dead if you live too far below it you
might not be able to survive because you
don't produce enough variability so you
have to be at or near the error
threshold but you can't be above it
because that means you have too many
mutations in your genome and you won't
make viable viruses so remember in a
genome of ten thousand bases you can you
can only sustain a certain number of
mutations otherwise the virus will not
be viable that number is the error
threshold so RNA virus has evolved very
close to it I'm going to show you some
data for that in a minute and DNA
viruses do not they evolved far below
their error threshold so that's why
they're a little bit less a lot less
successful than RNA viruses so here's an
example of an experiment using a DNA
virus we infect cells and then we
affects those with the DNA virus and
then we add a base analogue which in
this case is five azasite adine and this
is incorporated as a see into DNA it's a
modified see residue but when it's time
to copy it it looks like a t2 the
polymerase not a see so the polymerase
puts in an a instead of G because as the
polymerase to make more mistakes than it
normally would all right so the
structure of this base is such that it's
recognized as a tee when it comes to
templating when you do this experiment
the mutation rate increases by several
orders of magnitude ten hundred a
thousand fold for a DNA virus so in
other words by adding this analog you
can really increase the mutation rate
but you do this with an RNA virus the
error frequency only increases two or
three fold as compared to two or three
orders of magnitude so these viruses
can't make any more mutations well they
probably do but they're dead so adding
the drug does result in incorporation of
of A's and many many genomes but they're
dead because they've already got so many
mutations or right at the error
threshold and I can't go over it now
there is a drug that is used to combat
many virus infections it's called
ribavirin it's a very it's a rather
broad-spectrum antiviral and for certain
viruses it's been shown what this drug
does is to push the virus over the error
threshold okay that's why it has
antiviral effects in fact people are
wondering whether we can use this
property as an antiviral to design
compounds that push the virus over the
error threshold so remember mostly
antivirals we talked about last time
inhibit a process all right receptor
binding or polymerization whatever but
this would not inhibit a process it
would make the errors go at a higher
frequency and would basically and
activate the virus so ribavirin for
polio is is a mutagen by pushing polio
over the error threshold you can select
for mutants that are resistant to
ribavirin okay you can select for
mutants viral mutants resistant if polio
that are resistant to ribavirin what do
you think is the effect of those
mutations that make the viruses
resistant to ribavirin
remember the drug pushes the virus over
the error threshold the idea the
mutations increase the fidelity of the
polymerase so the mutation is that one
of the mutations is a single amino acid
change in the viral / malays polymerase
that makes it less error-prone so it
lowers the error thresh or lower it
moves the error threshold so that the
virus can now accommodate what the drug
does so the drug can no longer push it
over the error threshold I guess it's
raised the error threshold so that the
virus lives at the error threshold
initially the drug pushes it over and
kills it but now this mutation raises
the bar so the drug can't push it over
that's why it's resistant in fact that
is the mutant that I was just telling
you about that has been used to show
that viruses with more faithful blue
races cannot compete alright I mentioned
a genetic bottleneck before so let's
talk a little bit about that when you
put selection pressures on small
populations this results in the loss of
diversity and the accumulation of non
selective mutations this often happens
in a laboratory when your viruses are
not as diverse as they are in a host so
for example to do this kind of
experiment we take a single RNA virus we
do a plaque assay we pick a plaque and
we grow up the virus from that plaque
and then we plaque it again and pick
another plaque and we keep doing this
over and over again so here's a
schematic of that so you plaque out your
virus you pick a single plaque and then
you could just directly plaque it again
and so forth you keep doing this so
these are very restricted populations
because they're only a few thousand
viruses in each plaque so the quazy
species is really restricted so what you
get is a bottleneck because you restrict
the virus to the progeny of a single
plaque and it's not enough variation in
that plaque to make the virus healthy so
a few thousand progeny viruses derived
from a single virus the initial virus
that you plaque so here's the little
illustration of that parent population
of viruses you have a bottleneck you
only get a few surviving individuals and
those go on to seed the next generation
this would be better if there were a
thousand different colored balls in here
right and then you would shake out a few
colors and then those colors would
predominate but this was written for
non-viral situation so it's not as good
so that's what is a genetic bottleneck
you are restricting the diversity of the
population by these plaque the plaque
passages so what happens in practicality
is if you do this 20 to 30 times you
will end up with a virus that can barely
grow because the genetic variation is so
low that these viruses are not able to
propagate under different conditions so
they're markedly less 50 in the original
population now the environment is
constant use the same cell as you do
plaque the plaque passage same
temperature same virus all you do is
impose the ability to plaque from one
cell monolayer to another so what
happened to hear why does fitness go
away so the answer is Muller's ratchet
which states and this was devised before
viruses were studied in this way that
small asexual populations decline in
Fitness over time if the mutation rate
is high so viruses of course have a high
mutation rate they need to they
reproduce asexually and here's the key
there small populations we don't have a
full-blown quazy species and as a
consequence we have a bottleneck so as
we've already discussed replicating RNA
viruses may quazy species they exist at
the loop error threshold and that's
important for survival if we restrict
the growth of this particular experiment
to cereal founders the bottleneck so
many mutations accumulate that fitness
decreases so there's very little
selection in this plaque the plaque
passage it's the same thing over and
over again you have a limited population
and you get a lot of mutations
accumulating that aren't selected for it
eventually they they kill the virus more
or less because there isn't a huge pool
of quazy species from which to draw a
surviving
so there it's a ratchet because of the
this mechanical metaphor each mutation
works like a ratchet which allows the
gear to move forward not backward so
this is a ratchet you turn this knob you
push the gear forward it can't go back
because it has this lock here so each
round of error prone replication works
like a ratchet and adds mutation at
every replication cycle and you can't
remove the deleterious ones because you
have a very restricted population of
viruses so this is what we've done in
that experiment so here we start out
with an initiative initial population of
genomes if you do a plaque purification
say you now restrict the new viruses
that grow up to something that looks
like this they will all have the these
three changes and they have a few others
but if you keep applying the bottleneck
which in this case is the plaque the
plaque passage you will have
accumulations of mutations but not a big
enough pool of viruses to correct those
mutations so as a result you lose
infectivity so this may seem
counterintuitive to you but in practice
it works we have seen this happen in the
laboratory here are some examples of
fitness decline doing to bottleneck
passages of different viruses here's a
bacteriophage 40 passages a twenty two
percent decrease in fitness same with
many other viruses as well vesicular
stomatitis virus after twenty passages
decrease in fitness so yeah you have to
keep this in mind if you are doing a lot
of passages which you may want to do to
adapt viruses to different kinds of
cells but at some point you have to
relieve the bottleneck now in the real
world there are often infections that
impose bottlenecks so the the key would
be infection by a limited virus
population and if you get infected with
small droplets of a virus produced by
someone else that's the bottleneck
because there's not many viruses in that
droplet when latent viruses are
activated from a limited population of
cells that's also similar to a
bottleneck or
when an insect bites you you're getting
a small amount of virus all of these are
similar bottlenecks but these are not
subjected to Muller's ratchet and in
nature viruses do very well they make
quazy species and animals so why is that
and how do you would avoid the ratchet
well you subject the more diverse
population to serial passage right you
don't pick us if you're doing this in
the laboratory don't pick just one
plaque pick 10 or 20 or 30 and pool them
if you need to do this and that way you
have more diversity so why is more
diversity good in this situation why is
if you pick 20 or 30 plaques and pool
them and passage then why would that be
better because when you have more
diversity you can construct a mutation
free genome by either recombination or
reassortment and that gets rid of the
bad mutations and substitutes for ones
that allow viral growth okay so the
simple fact of adding a greater
diversity in this experiment allows you
to escape the ratchet so you just pick
more plaques instead of one so you may
think that how likely is it that
recombination would restore the fitness
well you only need one viral viral
genome in the entire population that's
fit and it will over grow all the others
and predominate so if that one genome is
produced by a recombination just
randomly between two viruses and it
happens to produce a genome that is now
fit for whatever reason that will take
over so even a very rare event will win
the progeny will take over the
population so well this means diversity
is important for the survival of
individual members so remember we're
talking about virus infections on a
population basis but the population is
important for individual virus because
what comes out is really an individual
genome that goes on to the next cell so
if you take away diversity the whole
population suffers so this is a slide
that just shows you how reassortment or
recombination in this case would give
you a healthy recombinant here are two
viruses that are been
produced during this plaque the plaque
passage they have lethal mutations and
their genomes so they cannot propagate
but if you we combine the two genomes
you now have a healthy vile recombinant
as I said even if this is very rare that
one virus will survive all the other
ones won't be able to this one will and
it will replicate so the exchange of
genetic information is really important
in the viral world we haven't really
talked about it much in this course we
have talked about it in terms of doing
experiments but it's incredibly
important to allow viruses to escape
these sorts of ratchets that restrict
diversity now RNA viruses that have
segments like influenza virus and real
viruses they do they do a similar thing
they don't recombine they just
reassortment SAR mixed so it's the same
principle that kind of reassortment can
rescue the lethal genomes and it's an
important source of variation we've
talked about how reassortment is
important to generate new influenza
virus strains is the same for real
viruses as well so that brings us to
different kinds of selection that occur
we've talked about selection in general
but I want to talk about two specific
kinds that we see in virus populations
genetic shift and drift when viruses
replicate in an individual that makes a
robust immune response or a so-called
immuno competent individual viruses will
arise that can evade the immune response
either whether it's a t-cell response or
an antibody response remember you have a
diverse viral population among those
members there's going to be one that can
escape a particular antibody or a t-cell
and it happens all the time so there are
two kinds of such immune escape there is
drift and this is diversity that arises
from copying errors followed by immune
selection so this can happen every time
a genome replicates and this happens for
influenza virus and then there is shift
which is the kind of diversity that you
get after recombination or reassortment
as we've talked about before this is
this is relatively rare but it doesn't
matter
because the survival will predominate so
both of these happen very prominently
with influenza virus so we've talked a
little bit about the pathogenesis of
influenza and the nature the acute
nature of infection but let's go a
little bit into drift and shift and to
do that we have to understand a little
bit about the antigenic composition of
these viruses remember there are two
major glycoproteins in the virion of
influenza the hemagglutinin the h.a in
the neuraminidase the na so here we have
a che and na and because there's such
extensive drift and shift among
influenza viruses a system for
nomenclature has evolved where you have
to give a number to the type of a che in
the type of na that's on the particular
virus so it's at h x and y so so far we
know there are 15 different kinds of
hemagglutinin and nine different
neuraminidase is so you can have
different combinations of these in
various animals now the H 1 2 and 3
hemagglutinin are the ones that can
infect us viruses with these can infect
us and all of them can infect birds as
well okay these H's the H 1 2 3 4 0 a 2
15 have all arisen by drift over the
years and then reassortment of these
different ages and ends gives us new
pandemic influenza viruses every 20 or
30 or 40 years and that's what you see
in this slide let's start in 1918 for
which we have a virus is the first
outbreak or pandemic of influenza where
we actually have the virus because we
constructed it we don't have any viruses
for the pandemics of 1900 or 1889 but
from studying the serum of people who
live them we suspect that these were the
kinds of viruses that cause these
pandemic and h 2 and 2 and an h3 na but
we're not sure so in 1918 that pandemic
was caused by the so-called Spanish
influenza it was an h1n1 strain and by
studying viruses that circulated and
ducks it looks like this is an AV
virus that somehow jumped into humans so
all the RNAs are read to show that it
came from this red duck ok now this
virus circulated for many years until
nineteen fifty-seven it caused yearly
outbreaks of influenza because every
year or two the h.a would change one or
two amino acid changes imposed by
genetic drift and selection by
antibodies in the hosts but then in 1957
there was a major pandemic of a totally
different strain and h2n2 strain so this
is not recognized by any of the
population what happened was the h1n1
riya sorted with a duck h2n2 and the
yellow jeans came from the duck so this
is now a random reassortment that
happened somewhere we don't know what
species had occurred in and then that
virus somehow got into people and we
didn't have antibodies to them because
the H in the end were totally different
so it caused the global epidemic or
pandemic 1968 so that virus circulated
from 57 268 again in 1968 this virus
Rhea sorted with another duck virus the
blue jeans you can see a couple of blue
jeans and now this is an h3n2 so it has
a brand new hemagglutinin same
neuraminidase as the previous virus but
that was enough to cause a pandemic same
thing happened in 1977 now just in 2009
again we had a pandemic of influenza
virus the 2009 h1n1 which was a swine
derived virus and this virus again was
derived by reassortment in animals it
had four different parents it had one
parent was a virus that infected
Eurasian swine these are pigs raised for
the pig food market both in Europe and
Asia is it extensive trade between those
two countries so thats all these green
segments and you see two of those ended
up in the h1n1 of 2009 then a a classic
swine h1n1 this is a viruses that have
been circulating in pigs since 1918 a
human h3n2 and a bird virus so all of
these rhea sorted over a 10-year period
probably in pig
to form to intermediate viruses which
then Ria's sorted to form this and this
had all the right sequences to infect
people if people weren't around that
would never have infected them but of
course we make the pig farms so it's all
connected in fact the pandemic flu seems
to be have become more serious since the
emergence of pig farming pigs serve as a
nice vessel for all these strains to
replicate in any way it's an example of
how reassortment probably provided some
advantage to this virus say in a pig but
just by chance that virus happened to do
well in people so that's antigenic shift
major changes by reassortment or
recombination drift is again minor
change in fluid happens from year to
year as the virus mutants accumulate
they're selected by the antibody
response in populations and eventually
you you have viruses with single amino
acid changes in the hemagglutinin right
at the tip and these are near sites
where antibody is usually bind to
neutralize infectivity and so this is
why we have to change the vaccine every
few years because you have a gradual
accumulation of mutations again it's
selected by our antibody response virus
can tolerate these changes so it slowly
escapes the antibody response and you
have to make a new vaccine because the
old one doesn't work anymore so that's
antigenic drift some other examples of
exchange of genetic information we've
talked about reassortment as a means of
exchange is also ways in which you put
non viral nucleic information nucleic
acid information into viral genomes we
have talked about most of these so far
in this course dr. Silverstein talked
about recombination leading to the
production of site open file divorce and
cows the production of oncogenic
retroviruses remember picking up
oncogenes from the host cell by RNA
tumor viruses this is an example of
exchange of genetic information and
viruses that have picked up virulence
genes related to host immune defense
genes
viruses have homologues of cytokines or
cytokine receptors at some point in
evolutions those came from the host cell
there was some selection imposed on
those viruses that randomly acquired
those this is just a diagram of the
bovine viral diarrhea recombination
event this virus here the genome of this
virus and RNA virus this virus is non
cytopathic in cows but a very low
frequency it Rick's up a piece of RNA
from the host cell that encodes a
ubiquitin cleavage site so that's what
you see H stand for ubiquitin is a
protease found in host cells so it's
picked up the cleavage site there are
two different kinds of viruses one with
the cleavage site put here and another
here the result is now the these
proteins can be cleaved whereas
previously they are not by cellular
proteases and the virus is more virulent
as a result so this is a chance
recombination event that occurred during
infection but it has a powerful
advantage so it's selected for another
example of how evolution proceeds this
one by host switching and recombination
and this involves two viruses very
interesting story one of them are circle
viruses these are vertebrate DNA viruses
really small genomes don't encode many
proteins and the other is a nanovirus
same genome structure but they infect
plants so we have Serco's and nano
viruses the rep genes now these viruses
encode a protein called rep which is not
a polymerase but it's needed for DNA
replication it's called a rep these are
hybrids of the two viruses if you look
at the sequence you can see that both
viral genomes are present in these
sequences these they also have homology
with the rna-binding protein of a virus
from a different family that Calissa
viruses the hypothesis having looked at
all this sequence information is that
the nanovirus which infects plants was
at some point long ago transferred to a
vertebrate maybe maybe a vertebrate was
drinking sap from a plans and thus a ped
virus in it so the plant virus somehow
got a hold in the vertebrate
and that established the circle virus
family so first they were nano viruses
the virus has jumped from plants to a
vertebrate and established the circle
virus family and then after that
recombination occurred between the
circle virus and a callus virus which
gave it this homology to an rna-binding
protein so you see there are many
interesting ways that recombination and
reassortment give rise to new viruses an
interesting question which we haven't
really talked about in this course is
while we're talking about selection is
virulence a positive or negative trait
of selection is this something that is
selected for or against we're all
familiar with virulent viruses that
devastate populations but it's that good
for a virus to be so very well and one
of the considerations is that increased
virulence reduces transmissibility
because if the host dies too quickly it
can't transmit the infection so this is
one argument why increased evolving
towards increased virulence really isn't
a good idea so if you accept that that
increased virulence isn't good you would
think that all virus has evolved to be
maximally infectious or transmissible
and a virulent right why should there be
any virulent viruses at all if they have
no advantage to the virus but we don't
actually observe this where there are
lots of viruses that are quite virulent
so there must be a reason for that and
one idea is that perhaps virulence
increases transmissibility so if you if
a virus causes you to cough and sneeze a
lot which is an increase in virulence
that will help it to transmit we see
also persistent infections that are
rather dormant for years so they're not
virulent but then at the end of the
infection they kill the host so there
must be some advantage to that kind of
viral lifecycle we also see cases where
there are viruses that are quite
virulent for one species but at another
animal very symptomatic so here the same
virus in two different species has a
very different variants phenotype so
we're not quite sure what the
relationship is
between selection of a virulence as a
positive or negative trait as i said
earlier maybe increased virulence
increases transmissibility and that's I
think transmissibility is probably the
most important selection factor so maybe
virulent sometimes comes along there's
no answer to that of course but those
are some interesting points now I want
to tell you about an experiment and
evolution that addresses this virulence
and selection issue this was done in
Australia and in 1859 the australians
brought in some european rabbits so they
could hunt them they liked to hunt
rabbits so they brought in these rabbits
and they multiplied but unfortunately
there were no predators of these rabbits
so they got out of control they were
just millions and millions of them and
this is one photograph from Australia
showing how many of these guys there
were so the Australians got upset they
said we have to do something about these
these rabbits so what they did is
release a virus a pox virus called
myxoma virus they said this move this
virus is quite lethal for these European
rabbits so the natural host of this
virus is from California and Central and
South America in those rabbits the virus
infection is not very harmful it is
spread by mosquitoes in the European
rabbits though which is not their
natural host the viruses ninety to
ninety percent fatal so that's why the
Australian has decided to bring myxoma
in and release it the mosquitoes would
pick it up and spread it among these
rabbits and get rid of them okay so how
did that work out first year of the
virus killed ninety nine point eight
percent of the rabbits but the point two
percent who survived they multiplied
like rabbits the second year mortality
dropped the twenty-five percent and then
the rate of killing and subsequently is
ended up being lower than the
reproductive rate so the rabbits are
still in Australia to this day this is
actually a topic that's been extensively
reported on in the press by the number
biologists so you can go back and look
at all this old literature so it was
it's an interesting example of
coevolution of the host and the virus
the virus doesn't want to kill all the
toast as far as viruses can want
anything so it evolved and the host also
evolved to be more resistant so there
are changes in the rabbits you select
for the survivors that can resist
infection there were changes in the
viruses so they wouldn't wipe out all of
the hosts as well so this is interesting
both rabbits and viruses produce large
numbers of offsprings probably why this
could be observed in such a short period
so the virus evolved as I've said to
kill fewer rabbits and then extend the
life so the virus could be spread in
mosquitoes so those virus is present in
the population that had this property
just randomly it was one of the quazy
species in the population were selected
for and those were the ones that
predominated and this is exactly what I
would predict an evolving host coming to
equilibrium with the pathogen so the
rabbit the European rabbit was a new
host for this virus so this is an
evolving relationship so both the host
and the virus you've also that both can
satisfy their needs so what was learned
from this you always get what you select
but you often don't get what you want
okay so they wanted to wipe out all the
rabbits but they didn't but the instead
imposed the selection which allowed both
to survive so this is a really bad idea
Tula try and eliminate any animal with a
virus however the Australians have not
learned because experiments are still on
going to try and get rid of these
rabbits using other viruses there's the
calicivirus Khaleesi viruses are RNA
viruses and they're trying to
exterminate the rabbits with them and
last year when I taught this course
there was just an article in the paper
where this virus had accidentally gone
out of the containment station where
they were doing limited experiments on
rabbits so another accident happening in
Australia so the European rabbits are
still there and the moral is that you
really can't get rid of them with this
approach because the evolution will
go its own way all right where did
viruses come from as I said we don't
know but we have some theories and
they're worth discussing there's the
regressive theory which says that
viruses are derived from intracellular
parasites that have lost most of their
genes there's the cellular origin theory
says that viruses arose from cellular
components that somehow got the ability
to replicate and there is the
independent entity theory I didn't make
up these names terrible names
independent entity viruses co-evolved
with cells from the origin of life I
actually like this one I think that
viruses were there before cellular life
evolved he may say how is that possible
because viruses need cells but that's
our definition today of a virus it may
have been they exist in a very different
form before cellular life evolved there
is a little bit of evidence for a few of
these when you look at the evolution of
viral genes which we'll talk about in a
moment but obviously we can't prove any
of it so we don't have any fossil record
not like we have of vertebrates we do
have genetic fossils we have viruses and
genomes of animals we can tell by that
how many millions of years ago those
viruses were around but we don't have
old virus stocks it's very hard to test
hypotheses but we do study contemporary
viruses and and get some ideas and so
here are some ideas from that about the
origins of viruses first of all there
are viruses of all three domains of life
the bacteria that eukaryotes the archaea
and they will have homologous features
to have things that make them look like
viruses and this suggests that the virus
has predate the last Universal cellular
ancestor also called Luca which is
presumed to be ancestral to the three
domains of life so maybe viruses were
there before these three branched out
the DNA viruses of green algae may be
the oldest ones there their genomes are
what we say at the root of most
eukaryotic sequences they are ancestral
to everything we know of in
eukaryotic world so we think these are
probably the oldest eukaryotic viruses
and as we sequence more and more viral
genomes we find more genes that have no
identity with any of the genes and us or
in any other member of the Three
Kingdoms so that makes it hard to say
that viruses came from something living
because they have genes that aren't in
any of these things so they're more
likely to be around before them so
here's an example of this some of these
very large viral DNA genomes that have
been discovered lately that Mimi virus
is 1.2 million base pairs Phi cognitive
irises these are viruses of algae the
ones that we think are at the root of
eukaryotic sequences these have sequence
coherence that means they're not mosaics
they are not mixtures of genes from
other viruses all the genes they have
are unique to those viruses haven't come
from anywhere else and that is difficult
to explain using a model that they arose
by getting genes from another precursor
genome so we think that these are very
very old viruses they happen to be among
the largest and that may be why they are
so big maybe they were even bigger at
one time and replicated autonomously and
then lost genes and became viruses these
mimis by the way if in fact amoeba we
now know over 1,600 viral genomes
probably even more today we can put all
those sequences on a glass chip and it's
called a viral chip and then we can use
that to probe environments for the
presence of some of those viruses we
don't have to grow all the viruses
anymore this has been a really powerful
development we can sample viral
diversity without having to grow the
viruses and we've discovered many many
viruses this way that we can't grow one
project was done to purify capsids from
the water so all the viruses in the
oceans have been sequence this way and
sequence the DNA and just see what's
there and when we do this when we do
these massive metagenomic studies we
find most of the genes are unknown
own we haven't seen them in any virus
and we certainly haven't seen anything
like them in cells so there's a huge
amount of diversity out there that we
hit that we haven't sampled but more
importantly for our discussion argues
that these viruses evolved on their own
and not from cellular forms here's an
interesting story of the evolution of
herpes viruses now you can sequence the
all the known herpes viruses and create
a time scale of evolution and when you
do that the three major groups the alpha
beta and gamma herpes viruses you can
calculate to have arisen 180 to 220
million years ago so that's not very
long ago in in life on earth so here's
formation of Earth 4.5 billion years ago
and the emergence of life may be 3.5
billion years and then here we have the
dinosaurs right about here 200 would be
250 million years ago and so we're
saying the herpes viruses probably arose
during the time of the dinosaurs not
very long ago but we don't have anything
before that so far also there are other
herpes viruses that infect fish and
oysters and amphibians they have no
sequence homology to these human and
animal alpha beta and gamma herpes
viruses they have a capsid like him and
that's why they're placed in the herpes
virus family but these may represent a
very early branch of the herpes family
because they have no gene homology to
the human herpesviruses smallpox by
sequencing 45 different isolates you can
put them in two clades that have
geographic clusterings is very all of
these viruses have the same number of
genes that seem to do similar things
very little diversity which suggests
that they were introduced recently into
humans and in fact just one has
significant homology to smallpox and
that is a pox virus from gerbils so the
idea has originated smallpox virus arose
after a zoonotic infection from infected
gerbils so zoonotic means going animals
to people so small pox which devastated
humanity may have a rose
zirbel a number of years ago papilloma
viruses and polyomavirus these allow
these small DNA containing viruses also
co-evolved with the host and a very
interesting story is that the
distribution of the six type 16 and 18
of these viruses is totally congruent
with racial and geographic distributions
of human populations so there are
specific populations globally that have
certain genotypes and certain variants
within each genotype so you can actually
map the movement of populations by what
kind of HPVs they have another virus in
this family JC virus is also a marker
for migration you can tell where people
have moved from Asia to the Americas by
just looking at the kind of a JC virus
genome that they have in them it's
really amazing and in this case the
infections appear to spread vertically
that is from mother to newborn which
would explain this kind of association
rather than being spread by respiratory
roots for example measles virus is
closely related to a virus of cows
rinderpest virus and we think measles
arose from rinderpest when humans first
began to domesticate cattle so we got
close to the cattle as opposed to them
wandering wherever it was they wandered
we start domesticating the right next to
them so we could pick up their virus
infections and in fact domestication of
cattle happened in the Middle East about
5,000 years ago and then the virus after
being introduced into humans spread
around the world like colonization and
migration and eventually was brought to
the Americas in the 16th century and
destroyed many many Native Americans
there who had not colonized cows and
hence we're not exposed to it previously
now an important point at the end of all
this is that viruses remain viruses no
matter how much they evolve okay this
despite all the replication in selection
we can see a herpes virus we can see an
influenza virus we just look at the
genome that's why a quazy species all
those variants week until still tell
what kind of virus they are
so there's a lot of opportunity for
variation but you do vary within a
master sequence of some kind how is this
so why do I retain well they are defined
by their capsids and their genomes and
the way they replicate so we think
that's a very strong restriction there
there's they all share fundamental
characteristics and it constrains them
so you any virus that can function
within this country's constraint will
survive but a DNA virus cannot become an
RNA virus apparently so we have now
seven different genotypes and no more
than that and that's probably all we
will ever see so any extreme alterations
don't survive selection going from DNA
to RNA and of course as I've said the
genome is one constraint as is the
replication strategy the nature of the
capsid you can't change from an
icosahedral caps into an envelope or
vice versa and there's also selection
during host infection you can't change
the way you infect the host or else
you'll be eliminated so that's what we
mean when we say viruses are constrained
by their structures and modes of
replication now new viruses we assume
will only arise for the ones that are
here right now we're not going to have
any totally new ones everything that
comes in the future will arise from what
we see so what is the number of all
possible mutations just to get an idea
of what's possible in fact it's so large
that it can never be tested in nature
when you sequence RNA viruses you see
that over half of all the nucleotides
can be changed in any given RNA virus so
let's do some numbers for a ten kilobase
viral genome that means there are four
to the five thousand sequins
permutations that defined all possible
mutants so we're assuming half of the
genome can be substituted so how many
substitutions is at four to the five
thousand and then it's probably bigger
because deletions recombination
reassortment would add to it but we're
not taking that into consideration but
the universe only has 4 to the 135 atoms
this is a huge number remember at the
beginning of this course we talked about
the total number of viruses in the ocean
which tend to the 30th I think which is
200 light-years away if you line up all
those viruses so this is even bigger so
what that's why we can't predict the
future so HIV of course gives you huge
opportunities for selected we do tens of
millions each day in a human you produce
billions of genomes a day and that's
where the number of 10 to the 16th
genomes for HIV comes from which we
ended up last lecture with and the
mutation rate is such that every genome
has a mutation and every human produces
genomes with many mutations that results
from mutation recombination and
selection so that's why we have
resistance every combination in use or
in the pipeline produced by chance every
day and most of the time they aren't
selected for luckily so virus evolution
really is relentless we will always have
mutants and the possibilities really are
unimaginable the only thing we can say
is that with the new viruses that arise
will be mutinous recombinations or
reassortment sorts of what is out there
certainly we could have two different
viruses recombine but they would both
have to be DNA viruses with the same
genome and the same caps it most likely
so they will resemble what we already
have we only know about 1% of the
viruses that exist on the planet now so
you can imagine that we still have a lot
to learn from this and I'll leave you
with this thought as mutation rates are
probabilistic and viral quasispecies are
indeterminate the concept of prediction
has little meaning so the numbers are so
huge that we can't really predict where
viruses are going but let me leave you
with this interesting tidbit it took
eight million years for simian primates
to change two percent of their genomes
to become human beings eight million
years in contrast polio can change two
percent of its genetic structure in five
days and that is the time it takes the
virus to pass from your mouth to your
gut five days and it will change two
percent of its genome so that's why you
see that viruses
can be so successful because they change
so rapidly so viruses are not cows
they're not humans and they're not to a
Drosophila a million years is really
nothing in terms of evolution and it's
unfortunate that we can't study that but
life has been around a lot longer so you
can imagine what viruses have done
I